>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
PICTURE THIS, SITTING EATING
DINNER SOME YOUR FRIENDS ON A
FRIDAY NIGHT.
DEEP IN THE CONVERSATION WHEN IN
THE DISTANCE YOU HEAR SHOUTING.
YOU LOOK UP AND YOU SEE A GROUP
OF DEMONSTRATORS WALKING DOWN
THE STREET AND YELLING AND
HOLDING FLAGS THAT SAY BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
THE GROUP IS LOUD, BUT YOU DON’T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH WHAT YOU
THINK THEY ARE SAYING.
OF COARSE BLACK LIVES MATTER
PAID YOU AGREE WITH THAT
COMPLETELY.
IT SEEMS OBVIOUS TO YOU.
YOU’RE AGAINST RACISM, EVE NEVER
MISTREATED ANYONE BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE.
HERE NOT A BAD PERSON.
AT FIRST IT DOESN’T OCCUR TO YOU
THIS MOB OF ANGRY PEOPLE MIGHT
BE ANGRY AT YOU VERY WHY WOULD
THEY BE?
BUT SUDDENLY THE MOB IS THEY ARE
, AT YOUR TABLE, SCREAMING IN
YOUR FACE, THROWING CHAIRS,
SMASHING GLASSES, SWEEPING
CUTLERY TO THE FLOOR AND
THREATENING TO KILL YOU.
WITHIN SECONDS YOU’RE RUNNING
FOR YOUR LIFE.
THAT HAPPENS IN OUR COUNTRY.
IT HAPPENS THIS WEEKEND IN
ROCHESTER.
HERE IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> [BLEEP].
>> WHAT ARE THOSE PEOPLE EATING
DINNER IN ROCHESTER DO WRONG?
NO ONE EVER SAID, NO ONE EVER
DOES.
HOW ABOUT THIS ELDERLY COUPLE IN
PITTSBURGH THEY TRIED TO GET
SOMETHING TO DRINK AN OUTDOOR
CAFÉ OVER THE WEEKEND WATCH WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> F YOU OLD MAN SCREAMS THE BLM
PROTESTER.
FEMALE PROTESTER CAME UP AND
GUZZLED THE OLD WOMAN’S DRINK.
WHY?
BECAUSE SHE CAN’T THE ULTIMATE
HUMILIATION.
WHAT DOES THE ELDERLY COUPLE DO
TO DESERVE THE ABUSE YOU JUST
SAW?
WHAT WAS THEIR CRIME?
IF YOU LISTEN TO BLM, YOU KNOW
THE ANSWER.
THEY LIVE IN AMERICA, THEY WORK
AND PAY TAXES, THEY SUPPORT A
SYSTEM THAT SYSTEMATICALLY
MURDERS PEOPLE.
IN EFFECT THEY ARE WAR CRIMINALS
, GUARDS IN THE WORLD’S
LARGEST CONCENTRATION CAMP.
THAT’S THE POSITION.
INCREASINGLY IT’S THE POSITION
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ARE
COMPLIANT USE MEDIA.
YOU HEAR IT EVERYWHERE.
BASED DON’T EVEN PRETEND TO
BELIEVE IT, THEY IGNORE THEIR
OWN SLOGAN.
IF YOU REALLY THOUGHT AMERICA
WAS A WHITE SUPREMACIST DYSTOPIA
, AND PEOPLE PLACE WERE
PEOPLE OF COLOR GET MURDERED FOR
GOING OUTDOORS AS THE DEMOCRATIC
PLATFORM SUGGEST IS TRUE, THEN
YOU PROBABLY WOULDN’T ENCOURAGE
MILLIONS OF NONWHITE IMMIGRANTS
TO MOVE HERE.
YOU WOULD BE TOO WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR SAFETY.
BRINGING PEOPLE FROM AFRICA FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD BE TANTAMOUNT TO
PREMEDITATED MURDER.
YOU WOULDN’T WANT THAT ON YOUR
CONSCIOUS.
OF COURSE IN REAL LIFE IT’S FAKE
, THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
AFRICANS DRIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
NIGERIAN IMMIGRANTS, THE UNITED
STATES BURN MORE MONEY ON
AVERAGE THAN NATIVEBORN
AMERICANS FOR THEIR ALSO MORE
LIKELY TO GET COLLEGE DEGREES
AND PEOPLE WHO GREW UP HERE.
BUT BLM IS TELLING US IS TRUE,
HOW COULD THIS HAPPEN?
BECAUSE THEY ARE LYING.
LOWER INCOMES AMERICANS, MELANIN
IS NOT THE MAIN BARRIER TO
ADVANCEMENT, EDUCATION AND
SOCIAL CLASS ARE.
FOR FOR POOR PEOPLE THE MAIN
PROBLEM IS MONEY, IT ALWAYS HAS
BEEN.
THEY DON’T HAVE ENOUGH OF IT.
THEIR KIDS HAVE EVEN LESS.
THIS IS OBVIOUS IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT OR LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
BUT THE RULING CLASS DOESN’T
WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY DON’T WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT TALK ABOUT
ECONOMICS BECAUSE IT FEEL IT
MIGHT DATE PROMOTE RACE CONFLICT
TO DIVERT ATTENTION FOR THESE
RIGHTS HAVE VERY LITTLE TO DO
WITH RACIAL OPPRESSION.
LOOK AT WHO IS WRITING.
DO THEY LOOK OPPRESSED TO YOU?
LAST WEEK AT THE NYPD REST OF
THE PEOPLE AT A DEMONSTRATION
HELD BY A GROUP CALLED THE NEW
AFRICAN BLACK PANTHER PARTY.
HERE ON THE SCREEN YOU’LL SEE
THE MUGSHOTS OF PEOPLE THEY GOT
ARRESTED IN NEW YORK.
THE FIRST THING YOU NOTICE IS
WHILE THEY WERE REPRESENTING
WHAT THEY CALLED THE NEW AFRIKAN
NONE OF THEM AS AFRICAN.
ONE IS DAUGHTER OF THE ARCHITECT
AND A CHILD PSYCHIATRIST IN
MANHATTAN.
ANOTHER AS A FINE ARTS MAJOR
THAT USED TO WORK FOR PEPSI.
A HIGH INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD IN
FLORIDA.
ANOTHER ONE OF THE WRITERS SPENT
HIS SUMMER JETTING BACK AND
FORTH TO ANOTHER HAS A MODELING
CONTRACT.
YET ANOTHER AS A STUDENT AT A
PLACE CALLED SARAH LAWRENCE
UNIVERSITY THAT’S A OVER
LEADERSHIP CLASS.
IT COST $60,000 A YEAR PARADE IF
YOU GO ONLINE YOU CAN FIND OF
THIS COMMITTED REVOLUTIONARY
SINGINGS SHOWTUNES AT HER LOCAL
YACHT CLUB AT LONG ISLAND.
THESE KIDS ARE NOT IMPRESSED.
EXCEPT MAYBE ON FAMILIAR ABROAD.
THEY’RE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
INTERESTING TO DO THAN GETTING
HIGH AND WATCHING NETFLIX.
FOR MANY OF THEM, UNDERNEATH IT
ALL THEY ARE FRUSTRATED AND
RIGHTFULLY SO BY VANISHING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
THEY SENSE CORRECTLY THEY WILL
NEVER BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS THEIR
PARENTS GENERATION.
FOR THEM THE AMERICAN GENERATION
HAS DIED SO THEY WILL NO LONGER
BE IN AMERICA.
ALL OF THAT COMBINED PROBABLY
ACCOUNTS FOR THE TO CLOSE THEM
YOU’RE WATCHING.
YOU DON’T NEED TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE DON’T NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHY IT RIOTERS RIOT
IN ORDER TO OPPOSE RIOTING.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS OPPOSE RIOTING
NO MATTER WHAT ITS JUSTIFICATION
.
THESE ARE THE FORCES OF CHAOS
AND INSTRUCTION.
THEY’RE WORKING TO TEAR DOWN OUR
COUNTRY GREAT THAT’S ALL WE NEED
TO KNOW.
IF WE CARE ABOUT OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR CIVILIZATION, BUT THE
FUTURE OF OUR DESCENDENTS, WE
HAVE GOT TO FIGHT THEM LIKE
EVERYTHING DEPENDED ON IT
BECAUSE EVERYTHING DOES DEPEND
ON IT.
WHEN COMPARED WITH THE
SUPPRESSION OF ANARCHY TEDDY
ROOSEVELT ONCE TOLD THE CONGRESS
, EVERY OTHER QUESTION
SEEMS INSIGNIFICANT.
THE IN OUR GUEST IS THE ENEMY OF
HUMANITY.
THE ENEMY OF YOU’LL ALL MANKIND.
HIS AS A DEEPER DEGREE OF
CRIMINALITY THAN ANY OTHER.
ROOSEVELT WROTE THAT IN 1908,
JUST SEVEN YEARS AFTER AN
ANARCHIST ASSASSINATED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WILLIAM Mc
KENZIE.
IN SOME WAYS, 1908 ISN’T SO
DIFFERENT OF A.
IN AMERICAN HISTORY IS THE ONE
RELIVING THROUGH RIGHT NOW.
IN 1908, AMERICA WAS FAST
BECOMING AN UNSTABLE COUNTRY.
MASS IMMIGRATION HAD MADE
SOCIETY FAR LESS COHESIVE.
NEW TECHNOLOGY COMPLETELY
UPENDED THE WAY PEOPLE LIVED IN
THE WAY THEY WORKED GREAT IT WAS
A RECESSION UNDERWAY IN 1908
COUPLED WITH HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
PEOPLE WERE ANGRY AT THE BANKS
AND BIG BUSINESS, ANGRY AT
CAPITALISM ITSELF.
THEIR WAS ALSO RACIAL UNREST.
DURING ONE RACE RIOT IN 1908 IN
SPRINGFIELD, ILLINOIS MOBS
BURNED BUILDINGS AND ATTACK
CITIZENS IN THEIR HOMES MORE
THAN A DOZEN PEOPLE DIED.
1908 WAS A CHAOTIC MOMENT, SO
NOT SURPRISINGLY SOME PEOPLE
BECAME RADICAL.
THEY CALLED THEMSELVES IN OUR
GUEST.
THEY VIOLENCE.
ONE OF THEM THROUGH OBAMA POLICE
OFFICERS.
I CAME TO THE PARK TO KILL
POLICE HE LATER SAID.
I HATE THEM.
THROUGHOUT 1908, THERE WAS AT
LEAST ONE NR GUEST BOMBING EVERY
MONTH OF THE YEAR IN THE CITY OF
NEW YORK.
SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU?
THEN, AS NOW, THE RADICAL LEFT
LEVERAGED ECONOMIC ANXIETY TO
FORCE THE PROGRAM ON AMERICA.
PRECISELY BECAUSE THESE WERE THE
SYMBOLS OF PERMANENCE AND
AUTHORITY.
THE ANARCHIST GOAL WAS TO TOPPLE
THE NATION ITSELF.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT KNEW THAT.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE SYSTEMS THAT
TOLERATE ANARCHY DON’T LAST LONG
.
IF MOBS ARE ALLOWED TO ATTACK
THE POLICE, WHY DO I HAVE TO PAY
TAXES.
WHY DO I HAVE TO OBEY TRAFFIC
LAWS OR FOR THAT MATTER THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
ANYBODY ELSE WHO CLAIMS TO BE.
PEOPLE QUICKLY START THINKING
LIKE THAT WHEN ANARCHISTS ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE THERE WAY.
WHY WOULDN’T THEY THINK LIKE
THAT?
ONCE THEY DO, THINGS FALL APART
FAST.
SOCIETY ITSELF WAS AT STAKE IN
1908, AS IT IS NOW AND TEDDY
ROOSEVELT UNDERSTOOD IT.
OUR LEADERS, DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
DON’T UNDERSTAND THAT ARE MORE
LIKELY THEY DON’T CARE.
CHAOS SERVES THEIR PURPOSE.
CONSIDER BARACK OBAMA, OBAMA IS
A SMART MAN, A GIFTED SPEAKER.
MANY PEOPLE FOUND HIM INSPIRING
AND IT’S UNDERSTANDABLE WHY.
WHEN THE FOG LIFTED AFTER HIS
EIGHT YEARS IN OFFICE, WHAT WAS
LEFT?
A DYING MIDDLE-CLASS, AND NATION
RADICALLY DIVIDED BY RACE AND
INCOME.
A POPULATION SO HOSTILE TO THEIR
POLITICAL LEADERS THAT THEY
ELECTED DONALD TRUMP PRESIDENT.
BY ANY MEASURE, HE LEFT A WAKE
OF DESTRUCTION BEHIND HIM.
IN THE END ONE OF THE RELATIVELY
FEW WHO PROSPERED WAS OBAMA
HIMSELF.
THEY BECAME UNIMAGINABLY WEALTHY
, LEGITIMATELY RICH WITH
ESTATES IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY.
WHERE DID HE GET ALL OF THAT
MONEY?
NO ONE ASKS.
WE ARE TOO BUSY HATING EACH
OTHER.
OBAMA STICKS THAT HATRED BECAUSE
IT HELPS HIM.
HERE HE IS AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION THIS SUMMER.
>> AMERICANS OF ALL RACES
JOINING TOGETHER TO DECLARE IN
THE FACE OF INJUSTICE, AND
BRUTALITY AT THE HANDS OF THE
STATE, THAT BLACK LIVES MATTER.
NO MORE, BUT NO LESS.
TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO LEAD US
THIS SUMMER, TELLING US WE NEED
TO BE BETTER, IN SO MANY WAYS,
YOU ARE THIS COUNTRIES DREAMS
FULFILLED.
>> THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO LED US
THIS SUMMER.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE BARACK
OBAMA SAID THAT.
OBAMA HAS AN INTERNET CONNECTION
, HE SEES THE NEWS.
HE KNOWS THE SAME YOUNG LEADERS
HE IS PROMOTING ONSTAGE BURNED
BUILDINGS, LOOTED STORES,
MURDERED PEOPLE.
OBAMA IS SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT WHAT THE MOBS ARE DOING
ISN’T BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER,
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
RIOTS DON’T HEAL WOUNDS, THEY
CREATE THEM.
THE VIOLENCE THAT BARACK OBAMA
USED BRIGADES HAVE UNLEASHED ON
THIS COUNTRY IF ANYTHING
INCREASED RACIAL BIGOTRY AND
DISTRUST.
THE RIOTS HAVE ACCELERATED
SEGREGATION.
AS HIGHER INCOME FLEET RACIALLY
DIVERSE CITIES WHICH BY THE WAY,
LIKE ANY GOOD ARSONIST HE WAS
SURE TO EXIT THE BUILDING BEFORE
HE WAS REQUIRED.
SOMEDAY OBAMA AND MANY LEADERS
LIKE HIM MAY FLEE FARTHER THAN
THAT AN ISLAND OFF THE COAST OF
MASSACHUSETTS WON’T BE FAR
ENOUGH.
BILL BE IN SWITZERLAND BY THEN
OR AUSTRIA OR NEW ZEALAND OR
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY DON’T HAVE
TO LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
A SOCIETY THEY CREATED.
FOR THE REST OF US WHO PLAN TO
STAY, WE HAVE NO CHOICE, WE HAVE
TO FIGHT.
ANARCHISM GOES BY MANY NAMES,
RIGHT NOW IT’S CALLED ANTIFA  AN
BLM, BUT THE POINTS AND IS